welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode 6 Rick fending
your Mort which is a play on Defending
Your Life a 1991 Albert Brooks film
about a man on trial in the afterlife to
see if he gets reincarnated Dan Haron
has always had kind of a thing for clip
show episodes on sitcom like we saw him
make fun of this in Community season 2
episode 21 paradigms of human memory he
kind of treats clip shows as an exercise
to come up with as many Bonkers premises
as possible or for the writer room to
use there we'll never actually do this
pitch and then kind of showcase them as
a remember when we did this cutaway gag
from episodes that we actually never saw
this is how we got the Anthology
episodes of the past like
interdimensional cable one and two total
rickall Morty's mindblowers and really
the opening credits of every season they
always throw in a few [__] examples
I love these episodes so let's break
down this one for all the Easter eggs
callbacks and inside jokes that you
might have missed we open on Morty
finding Rick drunk on the floor of the
garage blowing some raspberries
apparently coping with the Fallout of
the unored ricken episode last time Rick
ended that episode in kind of a
catatonic state now that he's killed his
Nemesis but he could just be getting
drunk because it's a Tuesday he kind of
looks like the Rick that evil Morty's
Rick became after evil Morty gave him
that six-pack of foies but now our Rick
has moved on from foies to the hard
liquor Morty Cashes in a whole stack of
Morty's Adventure cards we first saw
these in the season 3 episode
vindicators 3 return of world Ender and
they came back in rattle star Rick
lactica after winning a bet with Rick in
the Meeks and Destroy episode Morty came
up with this kind of system of choosing
every 10th adventure and since Rick
doesn't remember punching these Morty
provides receipts and this list is
hilarious most of these are completely
made up we see zoril loock Death Race
memory planet and a subset for memory of
memory Planet which kind of seems like
Morty saying the memory of it was as
Vivid in legit adventury as visiting the
planet itself so it's kind of like an
Inception sort of deal then labal brain
Heist which kind of feels like Morty
referencing the snuffle snowball episode
where dogs brains were enhanced
interplanetary Cricket World Cup aisle
of mortis saurus there is a morisa surus
character in the mobile game pocket
mortis but this also kind of feels like
an Isla nubl reference a Jurassic Mort
beating baby zombie apocalypse times two
so you know it happened twice I guess we
never learned our lessons from the first
time it happened dark brunch Regional
Plumbing convention takes one to no one
getting good at yo-yo tricks chicken
sandwich waffle soda can grenade
business specifically the card 2 list
reads like complete [__] that Morty
made up or maybe just memorable
experiences for Morty that he just
counts as Adventures but you know what
there have been plenty of episodes on
this series that started as these kind
of innocuous quests like training crows
or getting sesu on S spaghetti night
that always Veer into something sinister
Rick accuses Morty of making them up
like he did the titles of an MS
readathon at his school which is Darkly
ironic because one of the symptoms of
multiple sclerosis is memory loss Rick
says don't grift a grifter Morty I have
friends in Cosmic places don't [__]
a bullshitter it's kind of a common
expression but I'm reminded of Walter
White calling out a similar student
trying to con him into giving him a
higher score don't [__] a [__]
yeah and it's pretty funny he how fast
Rick soers up just to win this argument
with Morty and to not have to do
something something so Rick calls in an
audit from The Observer which is an
allseen race of geodes The Observers
were also the name of a similar allseen
race of Mystery Science Theater 3000 who
carried their brains around in little
bowls were also of course reminded of
The Watcher from the Marvel Universe the
first memory titled Truth or Dare Rick
and Morty slide into a temple two attack
patterns in a giant glowing weak spot
Legend of Zelda tutorial ass [__]
yes of course the Zelda games are famous
for their handh holdy tutorials with
basic quests and easy enemies the whole
Temple glows blue and orange like the
shrines from breath of the wild but they
encounter two guards that look like the
nlike enemies from Dark Souls games one
glows blue with orange eyes one glows
orange with blue eyes and they say that
one of them tells truths the other one
lies which is a reference to the famous
thought experiment and also one of the
best scenes from Labyrinth to solve this
puzzle the trick is you have to ask
either of the guards which door the
other guard would say would lead to the
Escape because both guards will indicate
the same door which would be the door
that doesn't lead out so you would take
the opposite door but Rick finds his own
kind of incredible Rick Sanchez
workaround by asking
this guy's wife yes well how about that
he guessed right I forgive you yes the
liar says I forgive you because he
doesn't actually forgive him you get it
okay the next clip late night Western
where Rick makes Morty portal to a Carl
Jr to get a western bacon cheeseburger
while it's seems like it's nothing Rick
was banned from this Carl's Jr which
could have been for any Rick rated dark
sci-fi reason so who knows what Morty
had to go through to get this burger
could have been a valid Adventure when
Rick crosses off this one we also see
IRL FNAF simulation Five Nights at
Freddy's since this was a rick Adventure
according to Morty I just kind of like
that he might have pushed Morty into
reenacting a Five Nights at Freddy's
scenario despite it being a game played
by younger Gamers Rick and Morty has
parody Five Nights at Freddy's a few
times in the online video glorp D glor
plays 10 Tuesdays at Tinkles and in a
social media post with a fake movie
poster for Five Nights at Terry's
starring Scary Terry also visible is the
next case Maximum Overdrive with clothes
so maximum o Drive is a 1986 movie
written and directed by Stephen King
it's very campy and very fun the maches
come to life and start attacking
Humanity we see Morty and Rick in a mall
wearing boxes because clothes are
attacking and a bunch of clothes drop on
a woman rip her face off and start to
wear it rick flips to another page but
this is actually the very first page
covering cards one and two that we saw
before but if you look at it closely but
from this Rick reads the next case
Whistling Dixie this is the parody of
the Blade franchise Rick and Morty fight
vampires in Blade gear and sunglasses
the vampires burst into flames when
they're slashed with silver Morty even
has a little pencil mustache like Wesley
Snipes had they meet Whistler the
character played in these movies by
Chris Christopherson Whistler was really
blades weapons guy but here he just
spends way too much time describing a
new vampire killing weapon incorporating
holy water UV light mirror tipped wooden
steaks and dry age cilian garlic I love
the little scent trail from the garlic
but Rick Morty get bored and portal away
leaving him to die next they argue
people died so by your logic 9/11 was an
adventure The Observer starts to throw
into a 911 clip and Rick and Morty stop
him Rick and Morty almost did a 911
themselves in the season 4 episode prom
morus and it was a bit controversial at
the time so I'm not surprised that they
stopped The Observer from showing it leg
day is a clip that we've been seeing in
trailers for this season I'm a leg a leg
Morty this of course is a call back to
the pickle Rick episode which got a
mention from Evil Morty last episode it
seems like the writers have just kind of
a real LoveHate relationship or how
pickle Rick got Meed to hell like back
in the garage Rick is a crappy
unlicensed leg Rick t-shirt that says
Rick is I'm a leg Rick and Morty show
which kind of seems like a not to all
the goofy unlicensed pickle Rick shirts
that went around a few years back then
in a memory The Observer just cues up
Morty gets punched in the wrong spot
into one of Rick's cybernetic implants
he put into him that causes him to turn
into a boat and going through this
transformation frame by frame is just
freaky his eye pops out his leg and his
arm bulge and then he just bloats into a
boat and I love how the hall has the
same blue and yellow colors as Morty's
clothes the bullies sail Morty on the
Open Seas and Morty has to spit out some
sea water that goes into his boat mouth
but then the bully slaps the wrong spot
turning Morty back human again it's kind
of a Castaway Situation Big D Doug dies
leading Morty and the other bully to
punch Morty to try to turn him back into
a boat they're both sobbing but Rick
rescues Morty and leaves the other
behind come on the hamsters turned on me
Morty we got to go a little hamster hops
out of the portal I might be
overthinking it but knowing Rick this
might be kind of a Richard Gear
conspiracy theory Thing Rick and Morty
talks some [__] he thinks he's hosting a
clip show and I don't like his voice I
don't like his voice I don't like that
he's doing jokes yeah it kind of sounds
like the Observer is voiced by Dan
Harmon as it is pretty much his Don
parto voice from the interdimensional
cable episode Saturday night
the key is grouping them with thematic
connections so it's kind of fun to think
of this episode as the writers rebelling
against old man Harmon like they might
be asking to fact check his mental
archives if a premise has ever been done
before but then whenever they ask him
that he kind of gets carried away with
referencing a ton of old bits and they
can't really get any work done so Rick
just pays the Observer and then rudely
sends them off and while they're eating
burritos they hear him clipping outside
to diet shame them don't find a carb on
my plate Morty I'm all about that keto
no I'm a fats man give me all the F so I
guess some Adventure in question is Rick
trying a low carb keto diet where he
still just eats animal fat then the next
clip shows Rick bleeding out his
cybernetic guts looking exactly like
they did after he fought Rick Prime last
episode they are fighting an AP Borg an
eight Borg is actually a brand of NTS
Rick gets Morty to lick the inside of
his nostril which brings us back to this
bar the salty Rick and it's filled with
particularly salty mean looking
Roadhouse Ricks there's a chalkboard of
Morty bets like the Deathpool board in
the Deadpool movie and these bets in
include Morty marri's Mr poy butthole
which is already crossed out so
somewhere in the Multiverse Morty ended
Mr poy butth hole's single streak then
believe he's a ghost like a six cense
situation murder/suicide with President
stick tongue fully up an apg's nose
common law Maria hippo chug salad
dressing become Santa Claus drink toilet
water there's some stuff that's a lot
easier to get into than out of tight
parking spots complicated romantic
relationships financial debt first thing
you know your car is making a weird
noise then all of a sudden you're
staring at your grocery receipt
wondering if you really need shampoo
this month it's no fun PDS debt can help
PDS debt offers free debt analysis
service to help make getting out of debt
easier PDS debt has customized options
for anyone struggling with credit cards
personal loans collections or medical
bills they roll all of your payments
into one low interest free monthly
payment which makes it easier to pay off
your debt in a fraction of the time
everyone with $10,000 or more in
eligible debt qualifies there's no
minimum credit score required so even if
your credit rating is hurting you can
still take advantage of PDs debts offer
and save thousands of dollars in
interest and fees PDS debt is offering a
free debt analysis it only takes 30
seconds head over to PDS debt.com
rockstars to get your free debt
assessment today the Observer takes on
the whole family now first Beth a moment
she chugged wine hidden in the toilet
tank next Jerry who in this clip eats
cereal while watching something on his
tablet that is folded back propped up on
the counter which is just like classic
dad energy Rick throws away a diamond
Jerry goes for it gets a handful of
syringes his piss turns into acid
interrupting the party in the break room
down below as he screams I can't stop
once I start now summmer shame might be
the hardest s laugh this episode because
she just can't get selected by a hottie
snatcher as in a body snatcher but it's
a hottie snater it always takes hot
people I need to
know just that pause of her brain in
hoping she'll get taken but instead the
hotties next door get taken but not
summer in principal vagina space Beth
shame is just farting during a briefing
with bird person about dichotomus Daniel
we also see the crew that we saw her
with in Star Mor R turn of the Jerry a
crew also included a female squane the
rebel doctor and dichotomus Daniel here
makes sense that he would be playing
both sides because he is dichotomous
then we see several Clips Morty steals
cash from Rick's wallet where we just
see Rick's ID and in the photo he looks
drunk then Rick walking a Morty dog at a
dog show Morty and Rick preparing to
jump into a massive bat of whale seamen
which kind of feels like a bat of acid
call back as well as that barrel of
horse semen and Rick dependent spray
that ended up being Morty's Morty then
gets aggressive what you going to beat
me up like the piss guy hey a reference
to the piss master from the season 6
episode analyze piss Morty kills the
Observer and this is revealed to be a
clip at Morty and Rick's trial so in
addition to Defending Your Life the
second half of this episode might remind
you of the Seinfeld finale where Jerry
George Kramer and Lane are on trial and
being reminded of the worst things they
had done throughout the series yes
Seinfeld's finale was a clip show which
might be part of Dan harman's hatred of
this format because one of the best
sitcoms of all time ended with one of
the laziest written finales I love
Seinfeld the series went out on a high
but I just can't justify the ending
series that way Rick reminds us that
they already did this whole thing but
with Giants and we cut back to a moment
that actually was a flashback to a real
past RI Morty episode The Mi and Destroy
episode the one that really started
Morty's Adventure card as a tradition
where they killed a giant at top the
beanock and had to go through the whole
giant judicial system and then later in
that episode Morty was sexually
assaulted by King Jelly Bean arguably
Rick continues to honor these Morty
Adventure cards because he feels so bad
about what happened to Morty on that
Adventure an adventure That was supposed
to be harmless and fun but the show even
calling out the fact that they've
already done this is an example of
hanging a lantern in screenwriting
that's when writers call out hack
writing before the audience realizes it
to signal to them that the writers are
aware of the flaw we're just kind of
making a joke out of it generally you
can pull this move once per movie or per
episode but the trick of it is timing it
and that's why hanging the lantern I
think is a valid move for writers to
pull because timing it can be really
hard you have to time it precisely as
the audience starts to see what you're
doing if you do it too early they won't
get it if you do it too late they'll be
ahead of you so it's a kind of a hard
move to pull next we see a series of
Clips where Rick gives Morty a gorilla
gun which he learns it's not a gun that
turns someone into a gorilla but is a
gun that is supposed to kill gorillas so
back in the garage Rick gives Morty a
bully gun which Morty uses on himself
thinking he'll turn into a bully but
then we hard cut to Morty with a huge
hole in his chest so then Rick gives him
a real gun and says it's to shoot bad
people but it shoots out Jeffrey dmer
the cannibalistic serial killer Yes it
shoots bad people and since these clips
are no longer even about mistakes but
just them doing dumb things The
Observers debate whether these
characters have been growing over the
course of the series Series so next we
see a pet cemetery it's spelled the way
it is in Stephen King's novel as they
try to resurrect Ben Franklin using the
pet cemetery where the soil kind of
resurrects people and animals into
zombie form we've actually been seeing
this zombie out of the Grave shot in the
opening sequences of every episode this
season Rick tests the zombie soil to
collect data we see various clocks all
over the graveyard various Revival times
on notes they push a car in to see if it
will refill the tank they push a
kangaroo halfway into the dirt to see if
its legs will come back this just kind
of feels like the writers were just
debating pet Cemetery logic at some
point in the room they had wrapped Ben
Franklin and foil to protect him from
evil but it just cooked him and Rick
gets hungry there's a lot of cannibalism
this season and even The Observers call
it out there's nothing sacred to you two
and then in another clip Morty makes
Rick make his churo come to
life hi I'm Cher Cher Do You Want to
Have Fun let's go yeah the music here is
very much inspired by Randy Newman's You
Got a Friend in Me from Toy Story and
it's pretty much the Montage of Andy
playing with wood Wy at the beginning of
that movie by the way Jessica Clemens
and I our origin story is when we were
on a sketch team several years ago and
she wrote a Randy Newman bit for me to
play where Randy Newman would be hired
by people to break up with their
significant other for them by singing
this song it's not you it's me so Morty
and chy catch a Marlin deep sea fishing
with it looks like Ernest Hemingway
Ernest Hemingway did right to the old
man in the sea and Ernest Hemingway is
the subject of one of the darkest jokes
in this series I wish that shotgun was
my penis if it were you could call me
Ernest Hemingway I don't get it and I
don't need to then we head to West
Anderson's Grand Hot Tub Emporium that
looks like the titular hotel from the
Grand pdest Hotel we see overhead shots
and various hot tubs with symmetrical
Framing and vibrant colors exactly the
kind of imagery that Wes Anderson loves
to do in one shot Morty is wearing a
little orange beanie cap making him look
like Steve Zuzu from Life Aquatic then
Rick reveals Cher is functionally
Immortal so they have to abandon him on
a desert planet with normal churros
which is kind of like how Jesse gets
abandon in Toy Story 2 or Lotso in Toy
Story 3 a lot of Abandonment in those
movies another clip shows a Time Rick
just murdered for fun I did it Morty I
killed a versions of us that were in
Space Jam Rick and Morty are in fact
Warner IP and did have a cameo in Space
Jam to a new Legacy Rick says that those
to welcome death they want it out and
Morty by the way I forgot that was
reading Chicken Soup for the golfer Soul
Rick uses a third arm under his jacket
to play a clip of the other time he did
leg day and then plays back all The
Observers shame like when they watch a
guy drown and since that memory came
from another angle they realize two
observers watched him drown this guy by
the way looks like he's from the same
species as the one who married slow
mob's wife in the post credit scene of
last episode we see another Observer
selling bootleg DVDs he says he's got
Avatar 3 through six with incomplete VFX
but they're still blue I love this
because there are five total plann
avatars there's also a copy of Batgirl
which was famously shelved for a tax
write off by this parent company Warner
Brothers Discovery you can also see
Babylon Amsterdam Oppenheimer Rec Willam
several mushroom clouds on that cover
and then the social network 3 into the
metaverse with someone wearing VR
goggles another Observer offers two
homeless watermelons money to fight each
other we see the judge Observer having
sex with a prosecutor's wife calling
back the blue and orange guards from the
beginning of the episode just a lot of
using infidelity to turn people against
each other I like there's a photo of the
prosecutor Tom on the bedside table so
Rick and Morty use his fight to escape
and now Rick gives Morty 80 cents on the
dollar for the Punch Cards even though
he already gave him 70 cents on the
dollar and ripped up 30% of them so
basically meeting Rick halfway with the
70% that Rick said was [__] and
Morty says they say Rick fly through
space come upon something maybe I have a
moral objection stuff gets messy and you
ultimately bail us out yep which is
basically the premise of most of these
episodes Rick says they're back and he
gives Morty another gun so after some
heavy Cannon episodes the series is back
with the total Rick Hall sound Madness
that I actually prefer to the Canon
mythology of the series oh and under the
post credit scene Morty is frightened to
find a churro in his locker but Troy eat
it and it's just a regular churro but
then he also sees soon written in brown
sugar so remember there were exactly
eight churo sticks on that desert Planet
so I hope through off the series and the
remaining episodes we get exactly seven
more warning churos before chur gets his
true Revenge if you want to support our
Channel grab yourself some holiday merch
From Nerd riot. shop it's perfect for
all the good nerds on your holiday
shopping list follow me on social
platforms at EA boss follow new
rockstars thank you to Jordan Morris for
helping WR this breakdown subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
n